la corte suprema de eeuu escuchó hoy los
argumentos del departamento de justicia
y de los proveedores de aborto en este
país en su demanda contra el estado de
texas que permitió una ley que prohíbe
el aborto después de seis semanas
incluso en caso de violación o incesto
la mayoría de los jueces de la corte
suprema se mostraron en favor de revisar
la ley de este estado porque ésta
bloquea de manera inapropiada según
ellos la revisión judicial necesaria
cuando los derechos constitucionales
están en cuestión entre los jueces que
se inclinaron por la revisión de esta
ley antiaborto de texas están recabando
y emi con iberia que son de tendencia
conservadora y fueron nombrados por
donald trump los demandantes argumentan
que ninguna ley constitucional o
precedente de la corte suprema está
segura si la instancia judicial máxima
en eeuu se pone del lado de texas porque
esta ley contra el aborto se salta
procesos constitucionales y podría
terminar abriendo una caja de pandora
para que otros estados pues se terminen
saltándose derechos constitucionales
como por ejemplo el porte de armas